- If you are in this segment of the room,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] V-necks.
- V-necks? Yeah.
Would you clarify what
you're wearing? A V-neck?
- [Audience Member] This is a plunge.
- This is a plunge?
Yes it is, madam. It really is.
(audience laughing)
I knew that's not a V-neck.
I just wanted an excuse to carry
on a conversation with you.
It is a plunge. V-necks, thank you.
People here, what would
you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member]
Kinky historical figures.
- So you said kinky
historical figures or figure?
- [Male Audience Member] Figures.
- Figures. Do you have any in mind?
It's probably the popes,
isn't it? It's the popes.
Pope Innocent ain't no innocent!
(audience laughing)
So, kinky historical
figures. And what was-
- [Audience Member] Catherine the Great!
- Catherine the Great?
Yeah, I guess she was.
Yeah. If you don't know why,
you'll find out why in the rap.
Okay, Catherine the Great.
Kinky historical figures and V-necks.
Let's come to people over here.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] The Oxford comma.
- The Oxford comma, brilliant.
Thank you very much.
For those of you that don't know,
it's the comma you put after...
well, before an "and"
at the end of a list.
Great.
You can tell you're a Sunday
crowd. It's really lovely.
History and grammar please!
(audience laughing)
But also some titties. Also titties.
People over here, what
would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Trafalgar Square!
- Trafalgar Square?
Thank you for putting
on that accent as well.
Trafalgar Square, cool.
Trafalgar square, if you don't know,
it's in London outside
the National Gallery,
where we have lots of cool paintings
that I'm not entirely sure
if we're allowed to own,
but we do.
(audience laughing)
Trafalgar Square, V-necks,
kinky historical figures,
and what was your one again?
- [Audience Member] Catherine the Great.
- Catherine the Great? No, that was...
Your one.
- Oxford comma.
Oxford comma, how could I forget?
It's funny, that was at
the end of a list as well.
And then one final one.
This can come from anywhere.
- [Audience Member] Summerhouse.
Well, because we've said
"Top Boy," we can't...
That's the name of the
estate in "Top Boy."
It's too much "Top
Boy"-based trivia in the show
for a show that no one has watched.
I know Drake loves it.
That's why it exists.
But anyway. So, for one final one.
(audience chattering)
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There were so many. What did you say?
- [Audience Member] Ivan the Terrible.
Ivan the Terrible? Okay, cool.
Weird, 'cause he's not Genghis Khan
and he's not Vlad the Impaler.
He's like the kind of
third-ranking person.
You don't have to all
be history, you know?
You'll see if he really went to Oxford.
I did, but I studied
archeology, and that's not...
I thought it would be
just like Indiana Jones,
but, like, you don't
get a small Chinese boy.
(audience laughing)
And what did you say from over here?
Someone said something from here.
- [Audience Member] Snorting
ketamine off titties.
- Okay, cool, yeah.
It's that or Ivan the Terrible.
I'll try and remember one of them.
So to remind you, we have
V-necks, we have the Oxford comma,
we have historical figures who are kinky,
Catherine the Great is one of them,
not Summerhouse, maybe snorting titties,
yeah, snorting cocaine off titties.
- [Audience Member] Snorting titties!
- Yes, I know!
(audience laughing)
It's late. It's been a long week.
Ivan the Terrible, and
the other one we had was?
- [Audience Member] Crumpets!
- No, it wasn't. Trafalgar Square.
It wasn't crumpets, but thank you.
There's too many words, but we'll try it.
This is a freestyle.
It's a rap made up on the spot
based entirely on their suggestions.
Oh my gosh! There's an
incredible band here.
Would you play some music
for me, please, my friends?
That would be so nice. Thank you so much.
I'm very excited to hear what this is.
'Cause the other night, Red was surprised.
He didn't realize I was here,
so he didn't have a song prepared,
but now he's gonna make up a song.
(hip-hop music)
Oh, it's some little kalimba, steel drums.
What is this? This is fun.
Look at you with your magic fingers.
And a little tambourine as well.
♪ Kick it off, words
coming from my mouth ♪
♪ Apologies to man here saying,
"Rap about the Summerhouse" ♪
♪ That's an East London estate, Asher D ♪
♪ It's a "Top Boy" reference,
I give 'em for free ♪
♪ I'll be going to Hot Topic,
maybe Abercrombie and Fitch ♪
♪ I want to get a, not
a scoop neck that fits ♪
♪ Want a brand new one
that exposes my sternum ♪
♪ That's your little chest
bone, yeah, I prefer them ♪
♪ The V-necks I inspect,
make 'em so deep ♪
♪ Got some heavy sunglasses on ♪
♪ All the ladies weep when they see it ♪
♪ They're like, chest is basically bare ♪
♪ Feel self conscious ♪
♪ Why? Cause I've no chest hair ♪
♪ But it's fine though ♪
♪ Gianmarco, he be 'talian ♪
♪ All the follicles coming
out, you'd be tellin' ♪
♪ Some V-necks looking
so pretty, it's nice ♪
♪ Technically this is a plunge ♪
♪ But maybe those titties
can get some cocaine on ♪
♪ That's a fat line ♪
♪ I can get my nose down
there, have a mad time ♪
♪ Snorting all of these ♪
♪ Even though I usually don't do cocaine ♪
♪ But maybe for you, I won't ♪
♪ Well, that's a double negative ♪
♪ That's a grammatical mistake ♪
♪ If you want to get
an education and take ♪
♪ They're like, you've gotta
make sure when you start a list ♪
♪ You're like, name, name ♪
♪ And then don't miss
the little dash there ♪
♪ It's like an apostrophe
that's run out of helium ♪
♪ And slowly moves down to the line ♪
♪ That's a nice little image ♪
♪ Let me talk about a guy
who loved to pillage ♪
♪ And probably rape and
do other bad things, yo ♪
♪ Ivan the Terrible ♪
♪ Roaming around, causing such harm ♪
♪ There's no cause for alarm
'cause he's not Genghis Khan ♪
♪ So we ain't spreadin' all his DNA ♪
♪ Probably from Russia,
but back in the day ♪
♪ When they weren't being genocidal
maniacs invading Ukraine ♪
♪ And then we got some more, yeah ♪
♪ Straight from the brain ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ Whoa, get the cheers, it's easy to do ♪
♪ I'm over in London, what am I gonna do ♪
♪ Truly, I love art with all my heart ♪
♪ I'm looking on the map
of the Tube where I start ♪
♪ And then I travel here ♪
♪ I'm like, are all of you are aware? ♪
♪ I'm a tour guide now
in Trafalgar Square ♪
♪ Holding up a little
umbrella, maybe a brolly ♪
♪ And what's this? ♪
♪ Oh, well, you'll be sorry
that I explained this ♪
♪ I'm going to tell some ♪
♪ This is a column, and
on the top of it, Nelson ♪
♪ Nelson's Column, he beat
people in a naval battle ♪
♪ Trafalgar Square, well,
I could even tattle ♪
♪ I could tell, look,
there's the fourth plinth ♪
♪ From the start ♪
♪ They change it every
quarter of the year ♪
♪ And put a new work of art ♪
♪ If you've been to Trafalgar,
you'll know this is true ♪
♪ But the last one we're coming to ♪
♪ You put a real finger to your chin ♪
♪ Acting all kind of thinky ♪
♪ Make it a historical
figure that's kinky ♪
♪ I'm like, ooh, this
is gonna be fun, mate ♪
♪ She loves sucking horse
dick, Catherine the Great ♪
(audience cheering)